do you feel the vibes okay good
let me tell you my vision
my kids want to share a room in the new house
but one was an animal theme and one was a Dinosaur theme
so I thought how can I merge these two ideas together
and I thought of a mountain theme
on one wall we're gonna have this big mountain mural
and when I think of sleeping in the mountains
I think of the stars and the beautiful night sky
so I had to get this Galaxy Star projector
it has music it's Bluetooth
it has a beautiful night galaxy sky
The Galaxy Starlight is going to make them feel like
one is sleeping with the animals
and one is sleeping with the dinosaurs
it is going to help set the whole mood for the entire room
and of course I had to try it out to see if it fit the vibe
and my kids are already so obsessed
this is their favorite thing at that time
so if your kids love the Galaxy Stars
all the things you wanna get this too